you know people in this room are scared  shitless of 30 it means nothing but our  society has decided to tell you that you  have to figure it out and married and  children and what are you talking about  98 of the 59 year olds i know don't have  it figured out the hell are we supposed  to have it all figured out at 30. people  are making terrible decisions getting  married because they think they're  supposed to by this age buying homes  because they think they're supposed like  all that humans do are create their own  jails and then live within it when i  look at this young of a crowd they're  living to 110. there's an enormous  amount of people in here that are going  to live to 110 and are freaking out that  they don't have it figured out by 30.  you're not even a [ __ ] quarter of the  way there yet  what are we talking about